bonsoir et bienvenue c'est ça vous
regarde et je suis ravi de vous
retrouver au sommaire ce soit la folle
semaine à l'assemblée malgré des
tractations intenses au palais bourbon
et au sommet de l'état c'est toujours
l'impasse parlementaire ce soir alors
quelles sont les options encore sur la
table elisabeth borne est elle la femme
de la situation ici toute cette crise
finalement été un mal pour un bien grand
décryptage avec nos invités dans un
instant sur ce plateau l'ukraine
désormais candidate officielle à l'union
européenne c'est une décision historique
compris les 27 aujourd'hui à bruxelles
on va y revenir avec notre grand témoin
c'est un amoureux de l'europe il est
journaliste dans l'âme aujourd'hui
député européen bernard guetta est notre
invité ce soir et puis 2 a franchi ce
soir de parti-pris retour en archives
avec grande baignoire est sur hull et
benjamin de l'assemblée le record est
battu le plus jeune député à monter ou
non seulement et puis l'international
avec isabelle lasserre comment vladimir
poutine organise la famille dans le
monde voilà pour le menu de ces verts ce
soir
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs il n'aura pas fallu 48
heures aux oppositions pour rejeté la
main tendue des manuels macron même si
les tractations se poursuivent au sommet
de l'état et vous allez le voir elles
sont intenses à leur tour y voir plus
clair sur les options pour sortir de
l'impasse parlementaire 4 fines lames ce
soir du journalisme politique et de la
science politique bonsoir pascal
perrineau merci d'être là vous êtes
politologue professeur des universités à
sciences po paris bonsoir carole barjon
on sera ravi de vous retrouver
éditorialiste politique et grand
reporter à l'ops bonsoir nathalie segaud
soient ravis de vous accueillir sur ce
plateau cette journaliste politique à
l'eau à l'opinion et arnaud benedetti
professeur associé d université paris
sorbonne et directeur de la revue
politique et parlementaire va nous
rejoindre dans un tout petit instant
mais avant de vous donner la parole on
va revenir sur cette folle semaine à
l'assemblée nationale que personne
absolument personne n'avait anticipé si
j'ai bien compris on ouvre avec l'ani
blakowski tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane et bonsoir myriam
bonsoir à tous à tout d'ailleurs allez
on rembobine si j'ai bien compris ce
soir vous venez de le dire myriam si
j'ai bien compris on n'avait absolument
rien vu venir je me souviens vendredi
dernier j'étais dans ce studio à ce
micro et je vous montrerai les
projections de l'ipsos pour la
composition de l'assemblée donc vous
voyez on imaginait que au pire du pire
du pire ensemble pourrait obtenir 265
sièges enfin disons 20 de moins et puis
bien sûr l'autre surprise c'est que on
dit au mieux du mieux du mieux ben il
aura 50 sièges et en fait ils en ont 89
c'est devenu le premier groupe
d'opposition à l'assemblée peine le pen
la grande gagnante de ce scrutin non non
le gagnant c'est quand même le contraire
il en ciel mais bien quand la victoire
sans majorité absolue c'est une toute
petite petite petite victoire tandis que
marine le pen elle a perdu ok mais elle
a multiplié par dix son nombre de
députés d'ailleurs elle a fait la visite
guidée de l'hémicycle avec ses troupes
mardi exhaler voir qu'elle commentait un
petit peu ce succès en le mimant on
écoute l'excellent clément méric aux
commentaires c'est un moment évidemment
très important que le vide le groupe
rassemblement national marine le pen est
en train d'indiquer d'ailleurs sans
doute le l'endroit où elle siégeait
pendant les cinq ans passé ce petit
espace tout en haut à droite de
l'hémicycle alors à des taux de succès
de victoire je voulais dire c'est quand
même un très grand succès puisque ça
valorise atg stratégique a mis en place
marine le pen depuis 2015 et présente
systématiquement autant qu'elle le peut
à toutes les élections locales des
candidats et bien voilà une dizaine
d'années plus tard elle est vraiment
solidement implantés dans le pays donc
la prochaine étape c'est d'essayer de
convaincre les français que le fn n'est
pas un parti protestataire
pas un parti de gilet jaune c'est un
parti de gouvernement on écoute la
patronne vous allez voir que nous allons
abattre un travail très important avec
une grande compétence avec
sérieux c'est à dire à peu près
différemment de ce que vous avez
l'habitude de dire sur nous voilà marine
le pen il faut souligner n'est pas la
seule femme à s'être illustré cette
semaine à l'assemblée nationale l'âme
femmes qui ont accédé à des postes de
pouvoir tuer exposés mais au départ on
pensait passage je vous montre un petit
graphique qui vous montrent que c'est la
première fois depuis 1988 que le nombre
de femmes diminue à l'assemblée mal
elles sont moins nombreuses oui on est
passé de 39 à 37 % donc les femmes sont
moins nombreuses en revanche elles vont
jouer un rôle beaucoup plus important le
meilleur exemple c'est yael brawn privé
qui donc a été désignée comme candidate
au perchoir par le groupe majoritaire et
qui devrait donc être présidente de
l'assemblée à la place de richard
ferrand donc comme elle brigue ce poste
évidemment elle a plutôt intérêt à
caresser l'opposition un peu dans le
sens du poil surtout que ça risque
d'être agité donc en rendent hommage à
or berger encore une femme qui a été
élue présidente de renaissance donc ça
c'est la république en marche un jeu
décrit parce que tout change et bien
elle a quand même trouvé le moyen de
rendre hommage à l'opposition elle
écoute c'est formidable c'est la
première fois que la république en
marché que le groupe renaissance ont une
femme à leur tête c'est important
valérie rabault avait ouvert la voie
avec le groupe ps qu'on en apprenne
dernière mandature matile panneaux lui
avait succédé on a besoin d'avoir ces
représentations très paritaire et des
femmes voilà mathilde de panneaux
d'ailleurs qui a été réélu à la tête du
groupe 1 sonik exactement réélu à
l'unanimité tout simplement parce
qu'elle était la seule candidate je le
souligne il ya des groupes où on élit le
candidat et il ya plusieurs candidats
qui en avait pris 0 et l'eire plusieurs
modes m plusieurs au ps plusieurs
alors qu est reine et allez les filles y
avait un seul candidat donc là je laisse
le temps à tout le monde de réfléchir un
peu sur ça mais puisqu'on parlait de
matt hill panneaux en tout cas une
différence avec jean luc mélenchon c'est
jean luc mélenchon a attaqué la semaine
bayard avec comme d'habitude un petit
peu enfin comme c'était sa marque de
fabrique de bruit et de fureur en disant
on va renverser les abbés de bord et
mathilde de panneaux hier elle a plus
envie de faire des propositions on
écoute nous avons toutes et tous envie
d'être utile au pays
d'autant plus après une allocution du
président de la république hier qu'ils
rejetaient une forme de blocage sur les
oppositions je crois que ce que nous
avons décidé de faire en commun et
notamment d'être force de propositions
et d'initiatives parlementaires de re
parlementariste et la vie politique
française va à l'encontre de tout ce
qu'a dit hier monsieur emmanuel macron
et et aurore bergé alors le style berger
ça donne quoi elle a été donc élue
présidente de renaissance mais si on
réclame à l'unanimité un sonore de
m'engager je vous l'offre d'autant que
justement elle se félicite de la
féminisation des postes importants à
l'assemblée je crois que c'est une
première d'avoir une femme présidente du
groupe majoritaire à l'assemblée
nationale et demain d'avoir une femme
présidente de l'assemblée nationale donc
voilà si on ajoute en plus qu'il y à une
femme à matignon ça prouve qu'il ya
vraiment un progrès de la parité en
france mais je pense que vous passez
bloqué là dessus on va pas parler que
des femmes est ce que le fait que ça
soit des fans ça va vraiment facilité
des compromis faciliter les négociations
j'en suis pas sûr ça reste de la
politique vite à son président c'est un
garçon derrière nouvelle
merci merci stéphane ben oui c'est
toujours c'est toujours l'impasse
parlementaire ce soir alors nathalie
secondes on va essayer d'y voir plus
clair on a quand même quelques
certitudes
en plus depuis depuis ces dernières 48
heures il y avait deux options proposées
par emmanuel macron gouvernement de
coalition ou majorité d'idées texte par
texte il n'en reste plus qu'une seule
aujourd'hui on peut dire ça oui on peut
dire ça enfin dans la majorité considère
que la majorité il considère que c'est
mort pour si j'ose dire pour un
gouvernement de coalition là dans les
jours qui viennent qu'on puisse afficher
rapidement après il ne désespère pas d'y
arriver d'ici la fin d'année pourquoi
parce qu'ils sont donc là on va plutôt
vers dans un premier temps
contrat de coalition j'aurais été
d'idées majorité des tatars passé au cas
par cas
après ils sont quand même de ce à quoi
ils travaillent en ce moment c'est de
susciter des 1 un groupe où deux groupes
dans l'idéal
charnière avec lesquels avec lequel ou
avec lesquelles ils pourraient passer un
premier contrat de coalition
dans les semaines à la rentrée
l'hypothèse n'est pas complètement exclu
mais à terme il n'exclut pas là on va on
va revenir sur justement ces potentiels
groupe charnière on va essayer d'être
très pédagogique pour s'y retrouver
parce que la vie parlementaire n'est pas
n'est pas forcément facile à comprendre
pour je trouve ça chacun quand vous
dites il ils sont en train d'essayer
maïs oignon alors matignon travaille
beaucoup là-dessus l'elysée
et
bruno le maire dans son coin gérald
darmanin dans son coin c'est à dire que
celui qui amènera un contrat de
coalition à au président de la
république
la monnaie des changes ce sera matignon
si imaginons qu'un bruno le maire dise à
emmanuel macron à moi j'étais trouver 20
députés droite divers droite qui sont
prêts à faire un groupe qui nous
soutiennent qu'ils disent qu'ils aient
qui s'affichent comme
passons un contrat avec nous fait
passionnante point de vue de la coulisse
c'est quoi c'est une forme de mise en
concurrence deux de ses poids lourds de
ses ministres en gros si bruno le maire
a mène 20 20 députés si c'est gérald
darmanin si c'est plus facile à main
françois bayrou à l'extérieur ça peut
je le sens mais dans cette démarche mais
elisabeth bornes aussi un endroit avec
travail alors plutôt avec le centre
gauche avec les députés ps en rupture
avec la nuque les david habib etc mais
plutôt de ce côté là mais il avait donc
là
en tout cas il ya beaucoup de coups de
fil qui il ya une forme de darwinisme un
peu sociale qu emmanuel macron fait en
oeuvre et puis c'est le meilleur gagne
ces salles élèves ont même temps c'est
la politique c'est pas que emmanuel
macron ça se passe comme ça souvent
carole barjon pour comprendre le plus
simple aurait été de s'appuyer sur la
droite on l'a dit on l'a redit avec
pascal perrineau le soir du deuxième
tour ça coince alors est-ce que ça
coince complètement pas complètement est
ce que les élèves sont divisés ou unis à
l'assemblée mais pour dire non au
président ce que vient d'expliquer nos
très bien nathalie segaunes c'est
précisément quand on voit bien que
emmanuel macron travail enfin et ses
ministres
autour de lui travaille à susciter des
groupes charnières alors il y en a déjà
quand j'ai oublié utile je crois c'est
ça ben justement on va regarder de 7
parisien est plutôt aile gauche était en
parle ce matin le gauche et engrossé
faveur ni travail a suscité un
un deuxième groupe charnière qui serait
plutôt
comment dire teinté de à droite ce qui
est évidemment une manière pour emmanuel
macron d'éviter la coalition dont tout
le monde a parlé depuis les résultats du
second tour qui était la colle de lys
ion avec un parti on veut structurer
comme les républicains
parce que si c'est ça c'est un contrat
de gouvernement on a bien vu que député
républicain qui ont été réélus
hormis quelques uns mais en gros sous
qui ont été réélus sont des durs entre
camel vielles marley get ready gens ce
sont des gens qui en ont ce qu'il faut
pas se compromettre avec le président
actuel pour préserver éventuellement une
possibilité d'alternance enfin qu'il
puisse représenter incarner une
alternance en 2027 donc cette grande
coalition là au fond macron c'est
qu'elle n'est pas possible et du coup
effectivement on travaille à d'autres
solutions il ya là voilà vous en parliez
jean rottner par exemple dans le
parisien pascal perrineau président les
républicains de la région grand est qui
dit publiquement pleine page dans dans
le quotidien il va falloir travailler
avec emmanuel macron au problème c'est
pas un député alors ils engagent qu'il a
quand il dit ça en effet et il faudrait
rajouter à cela l'intervention
intéressante également de la présidente
des pays de la loire qui va à peu près
dans le même sens que celui de jean
rottner c'est tout même pas n'importe
qui parmi les leers et président de
région donc ça traduit certainement une
sensibilité qui pour l'instant n'est pas
sensible dans le groupe et l'air mais
vous savez la politique dans une société
devenue de plus en plus liquides ça
fluctue c'est également liquide ça peut
beaucoup bougé d'un mois à l'autre et
même parfois d'une semaine à l'autre
mais dans un premier temps est au fond
c'est assez raisonnable quand on cherche
à gérer le pays avec ce qui est une
majorité relative vous savez de
multiples démocratie en europe
fonctionne avec des majorité relative
est pas majorité absolue simplement en
france comme on est habitué
au camp contre camp à la nuit contre le
jour ou bien contre le mal on a beaucoup
de mal fonctionner avec une majorité
relative donc pour adoucir ce que peut
avoir d'un peu brutale surtout en
dessous de 40 députés par rapport à la
majorité absolue la majorité relative
actuelle on va mettre j'allais dire un
peu de beurre dans les épinards de la
macro ni alors il ya un peu de beurre à
gauche est-ce qu'ils vont arriver
vraiment à 15,20 la gauche c'est aussi
le parisien est vraiment très en forme
ce matin avec ce groupe utile olivier
falorni on va voir ça sa fiche est un
peu de beurre à droite avec justement
des hommes et des femmes qui traduirait
mais au plan parlementaire cette fois
les prises de position de jean rottner
de la présidente
de des pays de la loire
de meilleur bond guillaume larrivé de
mais il est battu guitare m'arriver
justement vous disiez vous disiez ça
existe les coalitions ailleurs il se
trouve que le présent la république
termine le conseil européen à bruxelles
évidemment parler d'ukraine puisque sa
grande décision du jour on en parlera
tout à l'heure mais il a aussi dit ceci
écoutez
il a pu m'arriver qu'on me reproche
d'avoir trop de pouvoir parce que des
majorités trop clair la france est dans
une situation parlementaire qu'elle a
connu d'ailleurs en 1988 peu de choses
de différence mais et surtout
affreusement banal au niveau européen
sur l'ensemble des états membres il y en
a une vingtaine qui ont des
gouvernements de coalition les certains
avec cinq six sept partenaires ou
d'autres qui a agi sans gouvernement
minoritaire donc je ne crois pas une
seule seconde la question qui nous est
posée à tous dirigeants européens dans
des pays on le voit bien où les
divergences monde parfois les extrêmes
montrent ce qu'on a vu aussi dans notre
pays
passer de bâtir des compromis pour
pouvoir convaincre tout le monde en tout
cas le maximum obtenir des majorités
constructif et donc je crois que c'est
ce que vous citiez deux de mes confrères
mais c'est ce que l'italie comme
l'allemagne ou fond c'est ce que nous
ferons
est ce que nous ferons et avec
l'ensemble des partis de gouvernement de
pouvoir bâtir soit coalition soit accord
sur des textes pour avancer sur un
agenda clair à renommer les titres c'est
ce que nous ferons c'est du futur c'est
pas du conditionnel on avait déjà le
sentiment de voix d'un président à ces
petits mist mercredi soir en tout cas
qui tendait la main à partir de son
projet possible gouvernable le chemin
existe pour vous il a raison dans sa
comparaison clairement il a raison aussi
dans sa comparaison historique avec 1988
ou en effet on avait un président de la
république avec michel rocard qui
disposait d'une majorité relative sauf
que comparaison n'est pas raison la
france de la vème république se sont pas
les régimes parlementaires qui sont les
régimes parlementaires allemands mêmes
espagnols même italien c'est tout à fait
différent parce que la vème république
quand même au père qu'on le veuille du
nom avec des majorités qui sont très
souvent des majorités absolues ou des
majorité relative qui disposent sur
leurs marges dallier qui sont considérés
comme à peu près sûr en 88 la différence
fondamentale avec 88 d'abord c'est qu'en
1988 le groupe parlementaire partie du
parti socialiste était un groupe
parlementaire avec 275 députés et 275 ce
n'est pas de 145 dans l'arithmétique
parlementaire m il ya quand même un
nombre de sièges considérable qui sépare
les deux configurations ensuite c'est
que en 1988 françois mitterrand et
michel rocard pouvait s'appuyer malgré
tout avec toutes les difficultés qu'a pu
connaître michel rocard lorsqu'il était
premier ministre avec deux groupes qui
étaient des groupes 1 sur la gauche qui
était le groupe communiste avec je crois
une trentaine de députés à l'époque et
un groupe centriste qui s'était
constituée en effet qu'avait joué le
rôle de groupes charnières et qui avait
permis notamment par exemple que la
motion de censure il me semble qu'ils
avaient été déposées contre la
contribution sociale généralisée
instauré par michel rocard ne soit pas
adoptée donc il y avait si vous voulez
d'emblée disons des alliés qui était
assez identifiable là pour l'instant on
voit bien que c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué quand même on voit bien que
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué et
beaucoup volatile est beaucoup plus
j'allais dire est certain est finalement
là où il y aurait véritablement quand
même qu'on le veuille ou non de manière
très claire et de traits de manière très
identifiable des marges de manoeuvre
pour essayer de constituer une majorité
qui soit une majorité j'allais dire
homogène sur le plan idéologique c'est
quand même avec les républicains sauf
que le problème on voit bien que les
républicains ont pris une autre position
que quand même l'élection d'olivier marc
alex c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire ne
constitue pas un signal très positif de
ce côté là pour le président de la
république et pour madame borne donc
toute la difficulté maintenant pour lui
c'est d'essayer si vous voulez d'avoir
des interstices non dans le dans le mou
dans le paysage parlementaire en
essayant de créer quelques groupes
charnières qui pourrait à un moment
donné venir d'une certaine manière
être divers gauche autour de l'activer
ou
ou divers droite on verra ça mais juste
après le groupe même le fameux groupe
utile qui est en fait je crois
comprendre l'héritier du groupe
territoire libéré
liberté c'est un groupe qui pour
l'instant n'a pas clairement dit qu'il
était prêt jeudi à se lancer dans ce
type d'aventuré ils sont plutôt même
dans une position distille d'opposition
d'autant plus que vous avez par la
danseuse dans ce groupe d j'allais dire
des gens qui ont des trajectoires très
hétérogène vous avez quand même trois
députés nationalistes corses je ne sais
pas quel live quelle va être leur
position aujourd'hui vis-à-vis des
manuels macron donc ça va être quand
même assez difficile et si le problème
venait aussi de la méthode macron ce
sondage m'a beaucoup surpris sept
français sur dix impute à emmanuel
macron la responsabilité de l'absence de
majorité absolue à l'assemblée au doxa
pour le figaro 70% mais c'est énorme est
ce que ça vous surprend ou pas du tout
non pas du tout parce que c'est
personnel je suis mais il en résulte 4
alors oui emmanuel et oui mais c'est
avant oui mais il a du mal à pratiquer
l'auto critique c'est pas le seul
ses nombreuses personnes qui ont
beaucoup de mal à pratiquer ce sport
pourtant très utile
mais mais mais il est le premier
responsable de la situation cet
accouchement interminable de du
gouvernement de la première ministre
cette stratégie qui paraissait qui
parait-il était très fine du silence
surtout en faire le moins possible
eh bien on voit ce que ça a donné et ça
crée en effet bien un tassement
extrêmement sensible un effondrement de
la majorité parlementaire et une montée
en puissance des extrêmes phénoménal la
téléphonie ip aussi je crois emmanuel
macron le 5 ans de maltraitance entre
guillemets des oppositions c'est à dire
que il n'acceptez jamais aucun
d'amendements aucune proposition de loi
venant des rangs de l'opposition
le comportement hégémonique du groupe en
marche à l'assemblée fait que l air n'a
pas du tout il ya un député a l'air
disait faut d'abord qu'ils commencent à
nous parler poliment alors est-ce que
voilà les français sont complètement en
phase avec vous je poursuis le sondage
emmanuel macron affaiblie par ces
élections à 83% sera empêché de mettre
en place son programme à 76% porte la
responsabilité de cette situation
politique à 70% carole barjon escaut
finalement continue dit au fond venait
d'un mois sur mon programme dit moi
jusqu'où vous êtes prêts à coopérer sur
mon programme pour ou contre mon
programme sur le pouvoir d'achat sur les
retraites sur le climat c'était la bonne
méthode c'est tout le problème non je
crois pas alors peut-être sait-il mal
exprimé mercredi soir mercredi soir oui
lorsqu'il a paris il a dit qu'il allait
à bruxelles pour 48 heures et ensuite
dans un deuxième temps il a dit à mon
retour donc voilà on est yes conclusive
moment qu'il donnait 48 heures aux
oppositions ça a été corrigé le
lendemain par la porte parole du
quai la balle dans le camp des mets
position n'était pas forcément là
franchement c'est pas comme ça qu'on
doit procéder d'ailleurs françois bayrou
qui est un de ses principaux alliés ne
s'est pas gêné pour le lui envoyer dire
qu'il fallait changer complètement de
méthode qui ferait du dirk ouverte et
réaliser autrement une ou deux mesures
des offert un joueur qui est déjà partir
de toute façon c'est comme fort or
coalitions possibles on verra
avec les éventuels groupe charnière mais
de toute façon si en attendant ça ça
sera au cas par cas du coup il faut que
ce soit forcément l'exécutif qui propose
un projet détaillé sur lequel ensuite
les forces les différentes forces
politiques du pays se prononceront et
c'est là où chacun est différent de
celui de la présidentielle il faut qu'il
fasse comme écoles
flamandes et mettons que c'est lui qui
doit faire le premier pas parce qu'on
est dans une forme de métaphore de
révision dans un compromis c'est pas
vous rallier à ma position un compromis
c'est la fait un pas vers l'autre
vanessa il a dit dites moi juste que
vous êtes prêt à coopérer oui mais sur
mon projet c'est à dire en gros pour ou
contre par exemple la connais pas
complètement c'est ça c'est clair des
projets ce qui dit mercredi soir ces
îles et que sur la méthodologie il n'est
pas sur le fond il dit mettez vous
d'accord dites moi ce que vous voulez
faire sur la méthodologie est ce que
vous voulez un accord de coalition les
uns et les oreilles ou est-ce qu'on fait
du cas par cas c'est ça il dit juste ça
et après on discutera en fonction de
votre réponse on verra si montmajour le
fondée mais on est on est un peu dans le
poker dans le poker parlementaire on le
sent il ya du bluff pour voir c'est un
peu ça au fond tu marques et clément
bonne dans l'opinion
ce matin c'est quand le spd en allemagne
forme un gouvernement de coalition c'est
à partir de son projet à lui de son
texte les partis en allemagne discute
avant que c'est la méthode assez
classique qui rappelle quand même qu'ils
ont la majorité relative mais ils ont
une majorité donc c'est leur texte alors
sert de base une chose est sûre dans ce
contexte qu elisabeth borne à les
fragiliser d'abord elle n'a pas été
choisie à matignon pour affronter une
crise institutionnelle que personne
n'avait anticipé mais on peut le dire
elle s'accroche en témoignent deux
interviews qu'elle vient d'accorder une
à lci et l'autre à paris match pour
montrer que malgré la surprise eh bien
c'est la femme de la situation vois ça
avec emma quand
loin du tumulte comme si de rien n'était
elisabeth bornes préfère ne pas se poser
de questions sur son avenir à matignon
ce matin en seine et marne la première
ministre visitait un centre de formation
des apprentis suis à la tâche que nous
on est à l'action qui a des sujets à
traiter qu'on les traite et notamment la
prolongation de ces aides à
l'apprentissage c'est donc celle se
terminer le 30 juin ne voyait sait
maintenant qu'il allait prolonger
aujourd'hui elizabeth borne est une
femme seule ignoré par son président qui
ne l'a même pas citée lors de sa
dernière allocution
actuellement sur un siège éjectable
sous la pression de ceux qui militent
pour son départ je pense que les temps
exige que le premier ministre ou la
première mini soit politique qu'on n'ait
pas le sentiment que c'est la technique
qui gouverne le pays mais au contraire
les sentiments profonds qui s'exprime
dans le peuple mais pour la chef du
gouvernement ces critiques ne sont pas
justifiées je sais pas ce que ça veut
dire technique voyez ci technique c'est
l'idée que je serai enfermé dans mon
bureau derrière des piles de dossiers et
que je ne saurais pas aller à la
rencontre des français que je ne vivrai
pas leurs difficultés que je ne
dialoguerai pas pour apporter des
réponses avec les organisations
syndicales avec les organisations
patronales que je ne travaillerai pas
avec les députés c'est tout le contraire
de ce que je suis pour le prouver si la
première ministre soigne sa com avec
cette photo détendu pour paris-match en
plein jogging qui contrastent avec la
une aujourd'hui de libération reprise en
écho ce matin par sébastien chenu
des mornes va accorder ses violons elle
va commencer à faire de la politique et
va découvrir ce que c'est plutôt que
d'être ce fantôme depuis sa nomination
elle va prendre acte des rapports de
force qui existe à l'assemblée nationale
et puis elle va nous respecter nous nous
la respectons elle va nous respecter
parce que derrière nous ce sont des
millions de français alors que la date
de sa déclaration de politique générale
n'est pas encore connue il y avait
aujourd'hui elizabeth borgne a consulté
les présidents des groupes politiques de
l'assemblée
pascal perrineau s accroche c'est une
évidence cette interview elle est aussi
à destination des manuels macron dont on
a compris grâce à l'opinion et à
nathalie seconde que voilà il ya une
réelle compétition qui peut être
pourrait déboucher sur un remaniement
dans quelques jours ou par ya plusieurs
scénarios elle est la femme de la
situation pour vous écouter personne
n'est capable de répondre vraiment à
cette question et ceux qui font semblant
d'avoir une réponse m'étonne
pourquoi parce qu'on ne l'a pas encore
vu véritablement à l'oeuvre jédir elle
vient d'être nommée il faut la laisser
développer dans les mois les semaines et
les mois qui viennent sa manière de
faire de la politique elle sait bien
qu'elle ait dans un poste politique il
faut la laisser cette injustice que dit
françois bayrou
vous souvenez vous on disait à peu près
la même chose de jean castex et on
disait à peu près la même chose
détiennent philippe de dédouaner je sais
pas pourquoi voilà si je sais
voilà donc c'est assez voilà et puis ce
sont aussi bien castex que philippe se
sont révélés être de véritables
politiques donc madame baume peut se
révéler être dans les mois qui viennent
une politique qui l'emmène alors
probablement il faut le souhaiter pour
elle en l'occurrence mais la vérité
c'est qu'il ya une différence
fondamentale là aussi entre je crois
edouard philippe jean castex d'un côté
et madame board c'est que l'un et
l'autre disposé e au moins d'une
majorité claire et qui était une
majorité absolue je rappelle quand même
qu'en 2017 lorsque
ming emmanuel macron
parvient à constituer une majorité
absolue il parvient constituer une
majorité absolue ne serait ce qu'avec le
seul groupe de la république en mars
donc on est dans une situation qui est
quand même très différente de celle de
d'aujourd'hui non mais moi ce que je
note si vous voulez ce qui est très
intéressant finalement dans la
déclaration du président de la
république c'est que au delà de la
question de la méthode moi je suis pas
sûr d'ailleurs qu'il soit très sur le
saint méthode aujourd'hui à ce stade
c'est que il essaye de gagner du temps
et ce qu'il faut noter surtout c'est
qu'en effet il ne cite pas du tout
madame board et ça ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que ils utilisent finalement
le premier ministre la première ministre
corps beaucoup de présidents de la
république par le passé ont utilisé le
chef du gouvernement comme un fusible
c'est à dire quand d'autres termes il la
met face à ses responsabilités de chef
de gouvernement deux chefs de la
majorité il part quelques jours à
l'étranger et il lui dit maintenant
débrouille-toi d'une certaine manière
pour essayer de constituer une majorité
parlementaire il ya quelque chose d'un
peu instrumental voir d'un peu cynique
dans le comportement du président là
depuis lille mais qui est conforme
finalement à l'esprit des institutions
le premier ministre il est là pour faire
l'ingénierie parlementaire quand on est
là pour essayer de comprendre parce que
les choses se joue en coulisse nataline
secondes en gros il ya une bataille qui
est en train d'être mené vous l'a bien
expliqué qui apportera le plus de
députés même si c'est pour des
coalitions
ultérieure au président de la république
c'est difficile on voit bien que c'est
compliqué groupes charnières une
vingtaine parsys a fait pas forcément 40
etc quels sont les scénarii possibles
elle peut rester
si cette majorité ne lui aient pas
apporté sur un plateau
comment comment le président vous
comprenez cette tactique ce qui me
paraît évident sexy elle lui apporte
même un semblant d'accord avec un groupe
charnière elle a gagné le droit de
rester enfin c'est évident qu'elle est
il pour remanier son gouvernement début
juillet mais elle gagne elle reste
évident après si personne n'apporte à
emmanuel macron cette solution cet
accord s'il ya pas si si les autres ne
font pas mieux qu'elle à mon avis elle
reste aussi parce que c'est quand même
compliqué de alors qu'elle on l'a pas vu
à l'oeuvre de delà de la virée c'est une
femme il y en a malgré les sondages
d'opinion qui ne sent pas très bon un
oui mais alors là emmanuel macron sur ce
coup là il est enfin il a montré c'est
quand même sa capacité de résistance à
l'opinion aux journalistes aux sondages
et aura donc ils se croient pas
forcément forcer la main il ya le
restera mais sauf qu'elle là pour le
coup on la verra à l'oeuvre a essayé
d'avoir texte par texte est d'aider
majorité et au premier
à la première au premier premier blocage
la ville elle disparaît à les remplacer
à l'idée et argent oui parce que il faut
quand même pas oublier que dans la
tradition le premier ministre remet sa
démission
notamment quand la majorité a perdu ce
qui est le cas est largement aux vins ou
plutôt qu'elle a gagné très relativement
on va plutôt dire ça comme ça donc remis
sa démission le président l'acceptent et
rome ou neurones sommes pas bons là
c'est pas ce qui s'est passé emmanuel
macron a refusé sa démission
donc à partir du moment moi il me semble
qu'après la vérité comme un signe de
fragilité pour elle plus tôt sinon il
aurait ri et nourri avec lui et non ce
que je veux simplement dire c'est qu'à
partir du moment où elle n'a pas
démissionné lundi matin
effectivement je suis d'accord avec ce
qui vient d'être dit par pascal et
nathalie elle va rester elle va rester
un moment probablement jusqu'à ce que
emmanuel macron eux constatent que le
cas par cas fonctionne ou ne fonctionne
pas on verra bien mais je pense que là
elle est lé lé lé palier pour un moment
alors on fait un peu voilà de politique
fiction parce que personne ne sait
vraiment ce qui va se passer si elle
reste est ce qu elle peut ne pas engager
la confiance lors du discours de
politique générale est ce qu'une
première ministre qui commença mandat à
matignon dans cette situation peut dire
bah voila je vous fais un discours mais
a pas de vote non mais ça s'est fait de
très nombreuses reprises sous la vème
république
ce n'est pas prévue dans la constitution
qu'il y ait un engagement à la suite de
la déclaration de politique générale par
exemple mba se privaient voiliers de
d'engager peut-être à ceux qui vous
regardent que cette question du vote est
crucial
sur le vote est risqué donc étant donné
la situation ça serait même extrêmement
téméraire
suicidaire allons-y suicidaire de
procéder à cela mais elle ne choquera
pas elle ne choquera pas il faut avoir
un peu tout et le sens de l'histoire
longue qu'on n'ait pas simplement le nez
collé sur l'événement et à plusieurs
reprises il n'y a jamais eu d'engagement
systématique de la responsabilité du
gouvernement à la suite d'une
déclaration de politique générale
nathalie segaunes ya aussi larmes de la
dissolution alors peut-être pas tout de
suite peut-être à terme mais elles
existent sur certains députés on a vu
qu'il est élu de justesse et compris
dans l'opposition est ce que ça peut
fonctionner en disant voilà moi j'ai pas
du tout envie de retourner en campagne
parce que je crains de cette fois ci pas
être élu ce ça ça peut ça peut marcher
j'ai cru comprendre qu'il elle terrorise
les députés aient l'air
parce qu'il est fait enfin c'est quand
même c'est difficile de tenir cinq ans
sur la position sur laquelle ils sont
deux de ne pas participer de ne pas de
ne pas soutenir sur certains textes face
à va être compliqué pour
certes on voit bien qu'ils sont sûrs de
1027 on voit bien ce qu'ils préparent
mais quand même cinq ans je suis pas sûr
que leur électorat se soit totalement
sûr sur la champ qu'ils ont dit nous
sommes dans l'opposition mais une
opposition constructive et on votera les
textes voilà au cas par cas le premier
test c'est le pouvoir d'achat oui ce
serait idiot ça sera le texte sur le
pouvoir d'achat mais si vous voulez en
fait dans la physique des forces
politiques à quelque chose de très
intéressant il faut essayer de
comprendre qui a le plus intérêt
finalement à ce que cette expérience
échelons rapidement et en fait quand
vous regardez la composition des groupes
et le panorama de l'assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui tel qu'il se présente vous
avez très peu de groupes qui ont intérêt
à ce que on aille vers un échec très
rapide
l'ailer n'y ont pas intérêt le
rassemblement national n'y a pas été ré
évidemment la majorité n'y a encore
moins d'intérêt les seuls qui
aujourd'hui au sein peut-être j'allais
dire de ce panorama aurait intérêt à ce
que l'expérience disons dérape assez
rapidement c'est peut-être c'est
peut-être la france est soumise d'une
certaine manière qui d'ailleurs en train
de prendre une position qui est une
position de d'opposition beaucoup plus
radical que les autres groupes
parlementaires alors si je vous entends
bien cesser gouvernable puisque tout le
monde se tient si j'ai bien compris en
tout cas pas d'intérêt à faire tomber
tout de suite ce gouvernement est-ce que
c'est pas un mal pour un bien est-ce que
c'est pas une grande opportunité pour
terminer ce débat ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est un mal pour un bien si
j'allais dire les politiques entendent
ce qui est en train de se passer en tire
des leçons
si on continue dans les postures
bipolaire de la vème république le bien
contre le mal c'est à dire qu'on refuse
j'allais dire de fonctionner qu'une
majorité des relative avec les idées
qu'il faut gouverner le pays avec la
majorité d'idées ça échouera cependant
on découvre si vous voulez les deux
faces de la du régime de la cinquième on
a connu essentiellement le régime
présidentiel même hyper présidentiel
doit refuser que la cinquième en fait un
régime parlementaire oui bien sûr ça me
c'est un régime on distingue une
présidentielle on se trompe toujours
c'est un régime semi présidentiel ou
semi parlementaire c'est vrai qu'il y a
un premier ministre un gouvernement vous
n'avez pas ça aux états unis et le
gouvernement peut engager sa
responsabilité devant l'assemblée que
vous n'avez vraiment pas ça aux états
unis qui est le vrai régime présidentiel
avec une séparation des pouvoirs strict
donc là on est en train de découvrir la
dimension parlementaire
accélérée du parlementarisme comme ça se
fait dans 95 pour chaussures je suis un
peu calmé rideau sauf qu'il ya une
petite différence c'est à dire qu'en fin
de compte avec le scrutin majoritaire
uninominal à deux tours le général de
gaulle et michel debré avait en effet
penser un régime semi-parlementaire mais
composé de majorités stables et c'est ce
que devait permettre en principe le mode
de scrutin
là en l'occurrence pour la première fois
un mode de scrutin qui ne souhaitent pas
totalement que c'est un saut dans
l'inconnu et écrire sur nos deux pattes
on va terminer ce débat avec vous
clément méric vous êtes dans les
tribunes de l'assemblée nationale après
cette folle semaine au palais bourbon
est bien celle qui arrive promet d'être
tout aussi intense avec la bataille pour
le perchoir c'est mardi que les députés
vont élire leur présidente ou leur
président alors à quoi peut-on
s'attendre clément
et bien myriam le programme regardé il
s'affiche d'ores et déjà sur cet écran
prochaine séance mardi 28 juin 15h
ouverture de la 16e législature pour
élire le ou la présidente de l'assemblée
alors vous me demandiez à quoi est-ce
qu'il faut s'attendre et bien il faut
s'attendre à ce que ça la dure assez
longtemps peut-être cinq ou six heures
pourquoi et bien parce que la procédure
de vote elle même est assez longue
regardez voyez la tribune qui est juste
en dessous du perchoir ces marches de
marbre de marbre et bien les 577 députés
vont démonter un à un à l'appel de leur
nom pour déposer un bulletin dans l'urne
et puis ça va prendre du temps aussi
tout simplement parce qu'il n'y a pas de
majorité absolue dans cet hémicycle vous
voyez là et que chaque groupe
d'opposition a décidé de présenter un
candidat ce sera sébastien chenu pour le
rassemblement national annie genevard
pour les républicains et puis on
connaîtra le nom du ou de la candidate
de la nuque mardi matin du côté de la
majorité bien on sait d'ores et déjà qui
est candidat s'il s'agit de yale brune
people à l'ancienne présidente de la
commission des lois elle part favorite
mais cela pourrait se jouer au troisième
tour car lors des deux premiers tours de
scrutin eh bien il faut obtenir la
majorité absolue pour être élu et donc
ce n'est qu'au troisième tour qui lie à
la majorité relative pour élire la
présidente ou le président de
l'assemblée nationale a noté qu'on n'est
jamais allé jusqu'à un 3e tour de
scrutin sous la vème république ce sera
à suivre en direct sur lcp à partir de
14h45 ça promet d'être une séance hors
norme c'est sacrément
oui une séance hors norme pour plusieurs
raisons tout d'abord parce que ce mardi
il n'y aura pas de gauche il n'y aura
pas de droite ni de centre les députés
vont siéger par ordre alphabétique et
cela va donner du coup quelques
voisinage un peu étonnant tenez prenez
par exemple aurore bergé la nouvelle
présidente du groupe renaissance eh bien
elle sera assise aux côtés de la députée
de la france insoumise clémentine autain
une autre députée elle est fille danièle
obono sera à côté du député du
rassemblement national julien odoul
autre point à noter les différents
ministres qui ont été élus députés
n'auront pas le droit de prendre part au
vote c'est logique c'est l'application
de la séparation des pouvoirs mais leurs
suppléments leurs suppléants eux-mêmes
n'auront pas encore le droit de siéger
doivent patienter quelques jours
la fera donc une dizaine de voix en
moins pour la majorité présidentielle et
puis un dernier point a noté le
président de séance eh bien ce sera le
doyen d'âge qui siègera sur ce fauteuil
que vous voyez là derrière moi il s'agit
d'un député du rassemblement national
josé gonzalez âgé de 79 ans est un cas
de figure qui s'est déjà produit en 1986
à l'époque le doyen d'âge était membre
du front national et ben merci beaucoup
pour tout ces informations qui ont fait
beaucoup sourire en plateau merci
clément méric rendez vous donc mardi
prochain 14h45 merci à tous d'être venu
décrypter cette impasse parlementaire
bon la lumière peut-être au bout du
tunnel on verra on va à présent
accueillir notre grand témoin c'est un
amoureux de l'europe journaliste dans
l'âme il est aujourd'hui député européen
bruxelles il siège dans le groupe mach
ronis renaissance bernard guetta va nous
aider à dresser le bilan de cette
présidence française de l'union qui
s'achève l'ukraine décision historique
aujourd'hui en pleine agression russe
est désormais candidate officielle à
l'entrée dans l'union européenne
nicolas cours et où la candidature de
l'ukraine à l'ue eux c'est la décision
qu'on retiendra de la présidence
française de l'union européenne
en parallèle de tout ce travail et de ce
contexte nous avons su si je puis dire
parachever celui-ci par les décisions
d'hier et le geste politique très fort
de notre europe à l'égard de l'ukraine
de la moldavie et la perspective
européenne aussi donner à la géorgie en
décembre trois mois avant la guerre
emmanuel macron avait pourtant des
projets bien différents pour une europe
désireuse de tirer les conséquences de
la crise sanitaire renforcer la
souveraineté européenne définir un
nouveau modèle de croissance ou encore
construire une europe plus humaine tout
un programme bouleversé le 24 février
les troupes de vladimir poutine
envahissent l'ukraine met l'europe au
des filles et oblige les 27 à parler
d'une seule voix l'union européenne
s'accordent à mettre en place pas moins
de six paquet de sanctions contre la
russie elle organise l'accueil des
réfugiés le soutien économique
humanitaire et militaire à l'ukraine en
lui livrant des armes par exemple c'est
encore la guerre qui met l'europe au
défi de sa souveraineté énergétique avec
la nécessité de rompre avec les énergies
fossiles russe non sans dissensions l'ue
eux s'accordent pour se passer à 100 %
du pétrole russe d'ici la fin de l'année
en mai devant les députés européens
emmanuel macron relance l'idée d'une
confédération européenne un signal
envoyé aux pays candidats cette
organisation européenne nouvelles
permettraient aux nations européennes
démocratique adhérents à notre socle de
valeurs de trouver un nouvel espace de
coopération politique
la france est encore présidente de
l'union européenne jusqu'au 30 juin ce
sera ensuite au tour de la république
tchèque de prendre la main bonsoir
bernard guetta bonsoir à vous et merci
d'être là l'ukraine candidate officielle
à l'entrée dans l'union européenne c'est
une décision historique
il fallait donner dans ce pays à ce pays
dans ce moment si particulier où l'état
graisser par la russie ce statut de
candidat c'était très important survie
c'est une décision historique pour trois
raisons la première c'est que réellement
on affirme une solidarité plus grande
que jamais plus profonde que jamais avec
l'ukraine et je crois cela très
justifiée la deuxième est que les 27
états membres de l'union européenne ont
réalisé que aujourd'hui avait finalement
quand même une dizaine si ce n'est une
bonne dizaine d'états européens qui
frappe et qui m'aiment tambouriner à la
porte de l'union européenne et qu'il
fallait leur donner une réponse la
troisième raison c'est que tous les
états membres de l'union européenne sont
parfaitement conscients que si on
s'oriente vers une nouvelle vague
d'élargissement il faut réinventer
l'union européenne d'une manière ou
d'une autre et puis pardonnez-moi la
quatrième dimension je crois
paradoxalement que c'est la plus
importante
nous commençons à nous rendre compte a
réalisé aujourd'hui que si nous ne
voulons pas que le 21e siècle soit le
siècle d'un affrontement bipolaire entre
la chine et les états unis que si nous
voulons exister eh bien il faut unir le
continent alors ça c'est passionnant
parce que pendant très longtemps on a
dit attention l'élargissement ne peut
pas être une fin en soi
c'est pas la vision de l'europe d'abord
sur le cren statut de candidat ça va
être un processus extrêmement long le
président de la république a dit et des
années voire des décennies alors est-ce
qu'on n'est pas en train de nourrir de
faux espoirs mais écoutez non parce que
quand on va proposer le statut de
candidat à cordes excusez moi le statut
de candidat à la pologne aux pays baltes
à la roumanie etc mais ça a pris très
très longtemps aussi bon finalement ces
pays aujourd'hui vous savez moi j'ai
connu l'europe centrale communiste à
l'époque dans les années 70 quand
j'arrive en pologne quand j'arrive en
roumanie en république tchèque en
slovaquie et c'est
invraisemblable l'ampleur du changement
qui a été réalisée finalement on si peu
d'années alors il faut pas dire parce
que le processus est long bien que c'est
un processus forcément décevant non les
résultats sont là c'est aussi un message
à poutine
quand on regarde les la réaction russe
le kremlin déjà minimisant parlant d'
affaires intérieures à l'europe tandis
que lavrov a expliqué qu'une adhésion de
l'ukraine ne présentaient aucun risque
ça veut dire que ça les ennuie ça veut
dire que ça les ennuie énormément et qui
ne peuvent rien y faire et qu'ils en
sont parfaitement conscients et comme
ils ne peuvent rien n'y fait et dit ça
n'existe pas non monsieur lavrov non
monsieur poutine ça existe beaucoup
cette liste beaucoup parce que l'union
européenne est en train de s'élargir qu
elle s'élargit à d'anciens pays de l'
empire russe etc et réelle ne s'élargit
pas d'anciens pays de l' empire russe
parce qu'elle voudrait morts sur le
territoire de l'empiré c'est pas ça
c'est parce que ces pays veulent la
rejoindre et il faut marteler c'est
évident at et se bat à mains nues mais
bien sûr aujourd'hui pour ses valeurs de
l'europe alors moi moi je voudrais
beaucoup comprendre sur cette idée d'un
d'une grande europe continent face à la
chine face à la russie on sait que ça va
prendre énormément de temps et on sait
aussi que le président a mis sur la
table une idée de communauté politique
européenne dont on comprend que ce
serait un grand cercle autour des 27
avec une forme de partenariat privilégié
donc il y aurait des avantages mais
qu'il n'aurait pas vocation à entrer à 6
ici qu'ils rêvent au décret entré au
moment où les négociations se est
achevée se marier ce que le président de
la république a voulu leur dit c'est
très simple c'est le statut de candidat
ne vous garantit pas une demande
d'entrée pour après demain évidemment
pas mais pendant cette période on ne va
pas vous dire que vous avez cette ut
candidats au revoir à bientôt on se
revoit dans 20 ans non vous vous
organiser dans une structure qui n'est
pas l'union européenne mais qui vous l'a
fait parfaitement bien dit qu'il ya un
dialogue privilégié et des liens
privilégiés avec l'union européenne et
qui vous permet d'attendre non pas
passivement dans un sas mais en acteur
de votre destin qui vous permettent
d'attendre l'entrée pleine et entière
dans l'union européenne si je vous suis
bien cette communauté politique
européenne même si voilà on va prendre
du temps on va voir combien de temps ça
me voilà se mettre en place c'est pas
pour demain mais si la vocation c'est le
grand continent on voit
que c'est bernard guetta que j'interroge
si la vocation face à un monde
complètement recomposée un nouvel ordre
mondial c'est le continent est-ce qu'on
a les moyens d'absorber tous ces pays on
a vu qu'à 27 c'est déjà très un
gouvernail pour ça qu'il faut changer
entièrement les aussi comment alors
qu'est ce que vous proposez leur écoute
et
je propose pour ma part mais je ne suis
qu'un député je ne suis pas présente
écoutez j'ai j'ai proposé ça déjà dans
un papier du monde ya presque deux mois
et j'ai appelé ça la fusée à trois
étages je pense que ça doit être l'union
européenne mais une union européenne
jacques delors le disait déjà quand il
était présidente de la commission il
parlait lui de cercles concentriques et
on voit bien il ya un centre mais il ya
plusieurs cercles différents autour de
ce centre bon moi je reprend l'idée en
parlant d'une fusée à trois étages à
l'orapa plusieurs vitesses mais bien sûr
on tourne toujours autour de la même
idée depuis 25 30 ans parce que
évidemment que chacun sans cette
nécessité s'agrandit évidemment
souvenons nous que quand on fonde ce qui
s'appelait la communauté pas déjà
l'union européenne en 58 nous sommes six
états membres et puis ensuite ça a été 9
12 etc on est à 27 ans n'était à 28 avec
la grande-bretagne avant son départ nous
sommes à 27 aujourd'hui et demain très
vraisemblablement demain dans 20 ans ou
25 ans nous serons 25 demain et sur du
long terme voilà on parle du temps
historique pas du temps politique bon un
jour nous serons 35 et un jour nous
serons plus nombreux encore pourquoi
nous serons plus nombreux et encore
parce que imaginons cette europe à 35 et
bien à ce moment là
finalement c'est presque quasiment le
plein du continent - excusez du peu la
fédération de russie et la turquie et à
ce moment là cette europe à 35 devra
forcément engager un dialogue non pas du
tout en vue d'une adhésion la russie
n'entrera jamais on n'en voudra pas elle
ne voudrait pas dans l'union européenne
mais en revanche on devra dialoguer avec
elle pour trouver des accords de
coopération et de stabilité de sécurité
continentale qui sont absolument
ce penseur alors ça c'est pour la big
picture comme thérèse les anglo saxons
si on revient à ses six mois de
présidence française
percuté par la guerre jamais les les
européens n'ont plus autant de décisions
fortes et aussi unis sur les sanctions
contre la russie sur la livraison
d'armes est ce que ça veut dire au fond
qu'on peut y arriver avec l'unanimité
malgré tout non il faut s il faut en
finir non il faudra il faudra en sortir
parce que on y arrive là oui je sais
c'est un miracle quotidien dans le
mensuel on arrive à ça mais il faudra en
changer tout simplement parce qu'il faut
aller plus vite et plus loin et puis
plus on va entrer dans le vif du sujet
c'est à dire des décisions à prendre sur
la politique étrangère sur les
investissements dans les industries
d'avenir et c'est plus les débats seront
évidemment dû vous savez déjà avec
l'embargo sur le pétrole
exactement et là ils imposent à leurs
fins ils imposent un blocus scandaient
lé vré mone scandaleux sur un accord
pourtant
euro-américain atlantique sur l'impôt
minimum sur les sociétés et monsieur
urban fait du chantage au reste de
l'union européenne aux 26 autres états
membres avec la petite hongrie de 10
millions d'habitants il fait un chantage
sur un sujet aussi important que cela le
l'impôt minimum et pourtant c'est un
beau minimum dieu sait qu'il n'est pas
élevé enfin au moins au moins ils
relèvent un peu des taux qui était
absolument scandaleux alors il ya un
autre point qui nous est apparu voilà
qui nous a sauté au visage pendant cette
période d'europe et la guerre c'est
c'est la défense oui bien sûr on a vu
chaque pays se réarmer pour ceux qui
n'étaient pas suffisamment l'allemagne
mais on voit bien que c'est un échec
l'europe de la défense au 12e parce que
c'est autant aujourd'hui et on a
l'impression que nous on a l'impression
que avancé sur ce terrain nous nous
reste voilà le domaine régalien par
excellence tomber c'est l'alliance
atlantique évidemment parce
qu'aujourd'hui il n'ya malheureusement
pas de défense européenne mais
précisément tous les états membres
réalisent à quel point nous avons besoin
d'une défense européenne
quand canton bien sûr quand on voit
quand on voit revenir la guerre au coeur
même d'un continent
pas du tout c'est pas une armée on peut
pas prendre 27 abbey national pour en
faire une armée commune c'est la recette
de l'échec tout le monde éclaté de rire
tout le monde éclate red river a juste
dit non la défense commune ces deux
choses c'est l'investissement commun
dans les armes de demain dans les armes
de demain celles que personne ne possède
encore dans l'union européenne et
peut-être même pas aux états unis woods
ou dans d'autres pays et c'est
évidemment les
la planification militaire commune c'est
ça la défense commune c'est pas une
armée comme le conte claire dernière
question bernard guetta comment vous
jugez l'action du président de la
république emmanuel macron dans cette
présidence française percuté par la
guerre on l'a vu voilà garantir l'union
et louis des métiers en même temps il a
pu blesser aussi un certain nombre de
mots concernant la déviation qu'il
fallait surtout pas faire vis-à-vis de
la russie écoutez j'ai trouvé ces beaux
mâles heureux je les dis je les écris je
l' ai même écrit à plusieurs reprises
dans plusieurs journaux dans toute
l'union européenne cela étant si je mets
ça entre parenthèses
je trouve que l'action du président de
la république depuis
sa première élection dans l'union
européenne a été pardonné moi de le dire
simplement remarquable simplement
remarquable parce que pendant cette
résidence pas seulement grâce à lui mais
largement grâce à lui mais des tabous
fondamentaux sont tombés sur la défense
sur les investissements communs sur
l'emprunt commun quand il le fallait sur
la politique commune en matière de
défense de la planète contre eux leur
échauffement quand même le green deal
auquel on est arrivé au parlement
européen s'est largement l'action de la
france et pardonnez-moi d'aig des
députés il arrive à trouver peut-être
des compromis en europe et va y arriver
en france parce que la chouette
il serait pas nécessaire vraiment pas
nécessaire que la france plonge dans la
paralysie merci bernard guetta vous
restez avec nous pour les chroniqueurs
des affranchis allez on les accueille
tout de suite pour leur parti-pris
brandon ouaret qui va à nouveau comme
chaque vendredi ouvrir ses archives pour
s'intéresser ce soir au profil des
benjamins à l'assemblée s'ils sont les
plus jeunes députés de la 5ème
république et puis isabelle lasserre d
excellentes page diplo du figaro qui va
revenir sur la manière dont vladimir
poutine organise la famille dans le
monde nous affranchissons de ces soirées
des bois cib oms farid abbès myriam un
soir brandon on commence avec vous alors
c'est la plus jeune assemblée nationale
de la vème république
48,5 ans en moyenne et 21 ans 21 ans et
tu as ma taille legayic un
indépendantiste polynésien soutenu par
la nuque et vous vous intéressez vous ce
soir au profil de ces benjamins un
député benjamin dans notre histoire pour
la première législature de la vème
république en 1958 le benjamin de la
promo c'est guy vasques et y il est
avocat il a 27 ans il a rejoint la
nouvelle formation politique du général
de gaulle l'union pour la nouvelle
république composée de nombreux jeunes
néophytes mais cette jeunesse ne
l'empêchent pas pour autant de renverser
au second tour avec
45,88 % un ancien ténor à la députation
et plusieurs fois ministre bernard la
faille comme basque et y cette année là
neuf autres jeunes ou des moins de 30
ans entre à l'assemblée des novices en
politique pour la plupart 1980 le
benjamin de l'assemblée et va devenir un
visage très connue des français ce jeune
pousse du rpr a fait des études de droit
avant d'être adjoint au maire puis
attachée parlementaire à la mairie de
sablé sur sarthe vous voyez de qui je
parle je crois oui en soi fillon et pour
sa toute première interview télévisée
vous allez voir le nouveau plus jeune
député de france n'est pas très à l'aise
devant la caméra et même presque gêné
d'avoir été élu
je ne m'attendais pas du tout à être élu
député à 27 ans j'étais là dans l'ombre
de joël depuis cinq ans puisque j'ai été
son collaborateur chargé des dossiers
sarthois en particulier et j'espérais
bien être ce collaborateur pendant
encore de nombreuses années c'est donc
pour moi une situation nouvelle est une
surprise
à l'époque j'étais ben jamais la
rédaction du nouvel obs je suis allée
l'interviewer il avait la trouille et
moi donc alors brendan en tout cas n'a
pas attendu longtemps pour imposer son
empreinte capillaires et ses sorciers
légendaire alors sous ses airs de
timides de dandy à 27 ans et trois mois
le benjamin de l'assemblée s'était quand
même est liée à une mine de rien dès le
premier tour avec 50 % des suffrages
dans la circonscription de la sarthe
2007 2007 c'est un homme politique issu
du ps quitté qui était lui le plus jeune
député de france c'est même l'actuel
ministre du travail et olivier du soft
et lui benjamin de l'assemblée en 2012
on a eu le droit au président normal
mais cinq ans plus tôt en 2007 on avait
le droit aussi aux députés normal
j'aurais demandé lundi par l'ats
c'est très bien mais trop c'est plus
facile sans permis dès 8 ans bon pas sûr
qu'il ait pris le métro très longtemps
encore moins aujourd'hui en tant que
ministre en a 28 ans et 10 mois olivier
du soft est élu au second tour dans la
2e circonscription de l'ardèche avec 53%
des suffrages on voit sur cette
infographie et ne parlait jamais de
parachutage avec olivier dussopt pts
2007 2012 2017 et même 2022 il a
toujours été élu dans cette 2e
circonscription là où il est né et là où
il a fait ses premières armes en
politique est l'art des chaleurs 2012
c'est une législature avec au bout un
record historique effectivement puisque
marion maréchal devient à 22 ans et 6
mois la plus jeune députée de toute
l'histoire de la république française
elle succède à saint-just élus en 1791
au lendemain de la révolution française
à 24 ans il faut noter quand même que
marion maréchal tirent profit d'une loi
qui date de 2010 qui abaisse l'âge
d'éligibilité pour le mandat de député
qui passe de 23 à 18 ans et vous allez
voir la jeune de la jeune étudiante en
droit à ça ce n'est pas du tout
impressionnés devant les caméras à la
différence de françois fillon et
d'olivier dit soft au contraire elle
adore ça
suis heureuse d'être la porte parole de
cette jeunesse française qui sera demain
le fer de lance de la nouvelle espérance
incarnée par le front national et par
marine dans ce magnifique pays du comtat
venaissin les français ne veulent pas de
ce monde froid où tout est fait pour
nous diviser les 1 s'adressant aux
privilégiés les autres aux profiteurs
la candidate du fn marion maréchal
remporte la 3ème circonscription du
vaucluse avec 42% des suffrages au terme
d'une triangulaire tendue devant l'ump
et le ps elle bénéficie surtout d'un
éparpillement des voix au second tour du
au maintien de la candidate socialiste
catherine heures kg beach les archives
de bord noir est c'est toujours
passionnant merci à vous il a bell ce
soir on s'intéresse à nouveau à vladimir
poutine vous nous dites la crise
alimentaire n'est absolument pas que la
conséquence de la guerre c'est le fruit
d'une stratégie délibérée orchestrée par
le par le crème et bien oui humiliante
parce que vladimir poutine encore une
fois utilise la famine comme une arme
politique destinée à servir ses intérêts
et la propagandistes du kremlin
margarita simonian l'a dit quasiment
noir sur blanc il ya deux jours au forum
économique de saint-pétersbourg je cite
la famine va commencer ouvrons les
sanctions et deviendront amis avec nous
car ils ne pourront pas faire autrement
tout notre espoir est dans la famine
difficile d'être plus clair d'autant que
ces propos de la propagandistes de
recherche ou des sont corroborées par
les faits sur le terrain les forces
russes bombarde les installations
céréalière ukrainienne et aussi les
pompes par où passent les convois
alimentaire alpilles les stocks de
céréales pour les commercialiser à son
profit on a vu par exemple des bateaux
transportaient les céréales jusqu'en
syrie un ami et un client du kremlin
enfin elles refusent de débloquer le
port d'odessa pour pouvoir exporter les
les stocks de céréales alors on comprend
bien le problème l'ukraine est un des
plus grands pays exportateurs de blé et
beaucoup de ces états sont dépendants
des états sont dépendants de ces
livraisons r pourquoi pourquoi organiser
cette crise alimentaire mondiale à bord
bien évidemment pour asphyxier
l'économie ukrainienne ensuite comme le
dit si bien la cheffe de rtc pour
essayer de contraindre les pays
occidentaux de lever les sanctions pour
imposer aussi ses conditions aux pays du
sud en afrique et au moyen-orient qui
sont très inquiet d'éventuels troubles
civils si le blé venait à manquer le
deal est simple du blé russe contre un
soutien politique à la russie la
manoeuvre vise aussi à faire basculer de
nouveau pays dans la sphère d'influencé
russe alors avant la guerre l'ukraine
était le deuxième contributeur au
commerce mondial du blé en 2022
l'afrique hall sera inférieur d'au moins
40% à ce qui était prévu la russie au
contraire cette année sa récolte de blé
a été excellente elle quand sans doute
reprendre une partie du marché ukrainien
mais vladimir a sans doute poutine
pardon un autre objectif en tête une
famine dans les pays du sud en train de
re a forcément de nouveaux flux
migratoires à destination de l'europe et
donc de nouvelles tensions et de
nouvelles deux divisions sur le
continent et pour lui c'est du pain béni
ces terres et bruno dit en quelques
secondes c'est le digne héritier de
staline c'est le digne héritier de
staline parce qu'avec les massacres et
les déportations la famine était déjà
une vieille habitude soviétique entre 31
et 33 staline avait en partie organisé
ce qu'on appelle le lot de morts la
grande famine qui avait fait entre 4 et
5 millions de morts en ukraine merci ça
fait froid dans le dos merci beaucoup
merci à vous bernard guetta d'être vaine
sur le plateau de lcp très bon week-end
à tous lcp revient la semaine prochaine
un évidement avec ça vous regarde mardi
en ce qui me concerne avec d'élections
et perchoir de la nouvelle présidente ou
président de l'assemblée nationale en
début d'après-midi à montoir et
[Musique]